[Music]
this place isn't what you think
I don't care who this guy is we're gonna
get out of this
Peyton Reed you are the director of
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania it's
amazing to get to talk to you oh thank
you nice having you so my first question
uh it has a little bit of background to
it you are one of only four directors
who have helmed three or more MCU movies
and one of only three directors who have
their own hero Trilogy in the MCU how do
you feel about that
listen I when we when we made the first
Ant-Man when we started shooting in 2014
uh I think in the back of your head
you're always like oh it'd be cool to do
a Trilogy of movies we grew up on
trilogies and now we're we're sitting
here about to release quantumania and
we've we've made a Trilogy uh it's
really gratifying because we got to
introduce and then progress these
characters Scott and hope Hank Janet and
now Cassie is a hero uh it's really
gratifying right and also that
Scott Lang was sort of you know an
outsider at the beginning of that whole
cycle and now in quantumania here he is
he's front and center with with hope and
they're the first Avengers who are
facing off against Kang the Conqueror
right who's one of the all-timer Marvel
villains in the comics realm so to be
able to like create Kang for the MCU was
was a thrill
foreign
[Music]
you're an interesting man
Scotland
um I don't know who you are but
you've made a big mistake
okay
I'm an Avenger
I've called the other Avengers you're an
Avenger
have I killed you before
what do you utilize our expanded aspect
ratio could you talk a little bit about
that process and specifically how you
went about using it in this film yeah I
mean it's interesting we shot little
bits of the other movie with IMAX but
this one we we really like part of what
we want to do is take the audience down
into the quantum realm and make it
immersive so we thought a lot more even
in the writing phase about when these
transitions are going to happen uh
there's a major transition you know
obviously as they get sucked in in the
basement they get sucked into the device
and then bang you know we want to just
assault the audience like you're in it
now man there's no going back here in
the quantum realm that was really fun to
design and also just take advantage of
that aspect ratio and really make it as
big and as immersive as possible uh and
then maybe one of my favorite
transitions is well I can't spoil this
can I spoil this is this for later I
can't we use a uh we do we we do a
little thing that's sort of an IMAX
curtain roll to introduce an appearance
of one of our characters later in the
movie and that was really fun because
that was something where we we took the
IMAX format and we really are overt
about it and we say okay here we go
we're shifting into this thing
um
to me at a time when movies are you know
trying to get people back in movie
theaters and remind people and I don't
know if it takes much reminding but
movies you know are a communal
experience like when you're there
there's one thing to watch a movie at
home it's a whole other thing to watch a
movie surrounded by friends family or
complete strangers in a room and you're
all there looking at a big screen and
you're in it together particularly for a
comedy as someone who came up in the
comedy world and doing comedy films and
there's comedy obviously in the Ant-Man
movies
to hear the progression of laughter
is the greatest thing ever and to share
that laughter with people you've never
met like that's something that the
movies do that it's a rare opportunity
right that to be told a story in a grand
format and IMAX to me like from the very
first time I ever entered an IMAX
theater it's like okay this is this is
it man it's it's bigger and it's more
vibrant and now to be able to shoot in
that format you know for me as a
director that's that's it right because
you you you can't recreate that at home
I literally don't think I could have
said it any better than that so I'm
never gonna try I'm gonna work right now
please please
um I'm gonna switch to some some uh they
may seem random but they're a little fun
right so you as a film lover yeah
um what would be one movie if you could
experience it all over again for the
first time in IMAX what would that be
well I'll answer this question because
because I did experience all over the
first time and it was a handful of years
ago when IMAX re-released The Wizard of
Oz
in 3D
and I I was someone who grew up watching
The Wizard of Oz on TV uh for years and
I'd seen it projected you know in a
theater in Los Angeles but when IMAX
redid it and did it in 3D it was a
revelation man and it really took a
movie that was made in 1939 and made it
come alive and whatever year that was
it's probably been 10 15 years ago now
but like that was something where it's
like well this is an interesting use of
it because we're making new movies and
doing all these amazing visual effects
but to take that movie from 1939
and reinvent it for IMAX it was a whole
nother piece of art right it really
recontextualized that movie and I
thought going in
uh you'll forgive me for saying this
like well this is gonna be kind of
gimmicky whatever and it was not it was
like it was it was taking that movie and
it made it feel really contemporary and
that would be a cool thing to see like
taking even more of those older movies
and reminding younger audiences
particularly like
um there is uh there's a lasting quality
to these moves Wizard of Oz you know oh
this is a Dusty old movie that my
grandparents saw but if you see an IMAX
in 3D it's like well this is a new work
of art man this is amazing and and I
that is one of the many things I love
about IMAX preach I would I would die to
see that in IMAX again great man I just
saw Interstellar the other day
absolutely yeah just wow you know like
Dunkirk and IMAX like that stuff is just
like you know you're there I'm running
out of time so I want to do one little
game with you okay it's a it's an ant
focused game so basically I'm gonna ask
you a few ant Focus trivia questions and
I want you to tell me if it's true or
false okay let's go okay first one the
bullet ant is said to have the most
powerful sting in the world yes
ding ding ding that's correct number
four on the Schmidt pain index wow I
that's the highest that
okay I'm gonna keep going we're gonna
come back to this there are over 12 000
ant species in the world more than how
many more than twelve thousand oh yeah
way more
okay you're two for two better than I
did
um third question an ant can carry 10
times its own body weight
yes at least
I'm gonna give it to you because it's a
trick question it's actually 50 so I was
trying to get you on that one yeah okay
okay yeah last question there are ants
in Antarctica
no false wow that's four for four I
honestly I think it's ironic because
it's called Antarctica
um yes uh so that you've won the game I
didn't even do anywhere near as close to
you thank you thank you last question
for you and then let's go home
why should fans experience Ant-Man and
the wasp quantumania in IMAX
well if I'm making a choice to go to a
theater and and quantumania is playing
in IMAX I'm gonna go there because uh we
as the filmmakers worked very hard to
create this Vivid world the quantum
realm and we want to take you the
audience down there to experience it so
uh IMAX seeing it on this massive screen
with beautiful sound that that's that's
the way to do it
I'm excited for people to see it I loved
it thank you so much for chatting with
me thank you
[Music]